quand les répartiteurs du service 9h
reçoivent un appel d'urgence chaque
seconde compte
ils doivent déterminer rapidement le
niveau de priorité de l'appel
l'intelligence artificielle pourrait
bientôt les aider à prendre la meilleure
décision possible
parfois la vie bascule sans
avertissement et chaque minute compte
les premiers répondants en savent
quelque chose c'est pas toujours une
question de vie de man mais quand c'est
une question de vie nos ballons on peut
pas se permettre de perdre des minutes
gagner du temps c'est le défi de l'udc
de montigny d'abord comme premiers
répondants pour les services médicaux
d'urgence mais aussi comme chercheur en
soins préhospitaliers comme chercheur je
travaille les chiffres je le travaille
avec des données mais c'est un pas très
mai contre avec les gens ce n'est pas
extrait du tout comment gagner son pari
contre le temps avec l'aide de
l'intelligence artificielle
avec intelligence artistes que ça va
permettre de faire si leur répondre en
urgence quand c'est une urgence ne pas
répondre dans l'urgence quand ce n'est
pas une règle une urgence pour mieux
distribuer des ressources qui sont
limitées pour bien répondre aux appels
[Musique]
c'est risible ans oui bonjour moi j'ai
trouvé ma mère elle est partagée que
pour relier notre lent êtes vous avec
elle maintenant tout se joue en une
centaine de secondes
la répartitrice pose des questions les
questions prédéterminé je vais vous la
surveiller de très près la répartitrice
entre les réponses
ce n'est pas elle qui décide du niveau
de priorité mais bien un logiciel
il analyse le niveau d'urgence en
fonction des réponses obtenues par
pêches vous laisse avec eux bonne chance
on a des appels ou on sait tout de suite
que c'est prioritaire si vous appelez
vous dites mon bébé et bleu on n'a pas
besoin de beaucoup d'informations de la
ressource et déjà envoyé on envoie
l'ambulance
[Musique]
s'il est facile de déterminer la
priorité de certains appellent d'autres
sont parfois plus difficiles à juger
notamment lorsqu'une personne est
retrouvée inconsciente dans ce cas le
logiciel ne prend aucun risque
mieux vaut dépêché les paramédics plus
vite que trop tard mais la broche n'est
pas optimale si on regarde les études
qui ont été faits aux états unis en
europe on parle de plus que neuf fois
sur dix la personne de besoin d aide
mais on aurait pu attendre quelques
minutes voire peut-être plus longtemps
que ça difficile de faire autrement
parce que le portrait de la situation
est incomplet leur est pas ça n'a pas
accès au dossier médical du patient pour
des raisons techniques mais surtout les
gars on peut pas partager cette
information là alors les répartiteurs à
excellent roman aux informations qui
sont fournies par l'appelant
c'est à dire on répond aux questions qui
sont posées même si le répartiteur
disposait des antécédents médicaux de
celui qu'ils appellent ils n'auraient
pas le temps de les analyser
un humain ne peut pas regarder ces
données-là faire un processus de triage
dans leur tête ou même avec un outil ce
qui va faire l'intelligence artificielle
c'est d'aller chercher des informations
sur la personne donc une richesse qu'on
peut pas traiter dans les seconds comme
ici pour donner naissance à cette
intelligence lutte de montigny s'entoure
d'experts notamment ceux de l'université
de calgary leur mandat développé des
algorithmes à partir des données du
ministère de la santé de l'alberta
comment va nourrir le modèle on a des
bios à titien qui ont déjà accès aux
données albertain pour commencer
développer ses modèles de prédiction
l'un avec ti faire technique
d'apprentissage e automatisés
l'intelligence artificielle a donc
besoin de donner deux beaucoup donné il
faut savoir que quand on fait la
prévision tout ce qui peut servir
on va mettre dedans si savoir la couleur
des yeux d'un patient ça va aider à
savoir si vraiment malade je vais mettre
bleus torrent vert
quand les algorithmes seront prêts on
remplacera les données albertaine par
les données québécoises
l'intelligence artificielle analysera
donc l'information médicale colligées
par la régie de l'assurance maladie du
québec et le ministère de la santé et
des services sociaux pendant que le
répartiteur pose des questions les
algorithmes analyse des données
médicales de l'appelant par exemple
l'intelligence artificielle pour à
savoir que les palpitations cardiaques
dont la plance plein ne sont pas
nécessairement la conséquence d'un
infarctus comme il le croit mais plutôt
la conséquence d'une attaque de panique
car le patient consulte un psychiatre
pour traiter son anxiété
une fois le niveau d'urgence déterminer
l'intelligence artificielle de l'envoi
mais sans l'expliquer
en tout cas ce qu'on veut faire c'est
d'aller chercher tout cette recherche de
données en santé pour elle une prévision
pour chaque individu au moment de la
prise d'appels pour savoir est ce que
c'est une urgence ou ce n'est pas une
urgence
sans parler de révolution
luc de montigny est convaincu que
l'intelligence artificielle mérite sa
place au neuf ans si tout va bien elle
pourrait faire son entrée à
urgences-santé dès 2023
[Musique]